[Musique]
[Rires]
oui
oui bonjour
j'ai rendez-vous avec le docteur
villadro
vous savez que le docteur villadreau est
un docteur aux méthodes pour orthodoxe
oui je suis au courant mais j'en ai
besoin vite très vite c'est exactement
ça docteur villadro
il y a Monsieur San José pour vous à
laquelle
bonjour au docteur je ne sais pas ce qui
m'arrive j'ai mal de là à la
déshabillez-vous tu vois ça de plus près
oh mais que faites-vous docteur ce sont
des méthodes portes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors moi je te raconte un truc mais pas
du tout excuse-moi tu peux rentrer
si on fait plaisir de te voir
Jean-Michel moi aussi un vrai merci on
t'en parlera tout à l'heure merci oui
ben vous avez bien de la chance faites
attention il crache non mais c'est vrai
parce que moi j'ai un gros problème les
mecs qui postillonnent quand tu vas au
restaurant ah mais je moi je ne fais
plus aucun déjeuner les gars et vous le
savez d'ailleurs je n'ai que personne
les gars sont sales il y a des gars ils
ont déjà cousines dans la bouche ça veut
dire que tu es en train de manger mon
frère il parle là-bas tu sens tu vois et
tu vois dans ton assiette tu sais que
c'est frère je ne peux pas lui la
cracher dans mon assiette un jour il a
craché dedans
je peux te voir mais au niveau de la
yatolisme
moi je suis une hygiène voilà irréproche
irréprochable moi tu vois je vais te
dire regarde c'est pour ça moi quand je
mange je ne parle pas
soyez côte à côté
avec moi ce con il a craché sur moi
il paye pas il a rigolé j'avais dîné une
fois avec l'ancien gardien le PSG
Bernard là-bas c'est horrible
[Applaudissements]
sur ça super tu ressors et tu reviens
pas tout de suite